[Musique]
à 30 ans et des poussières cette
championne de tennis vient de réaliser
une de ses meilleures années sur le
circuit si ça hargne Viva sur le cours
elle devra faire montre donc un peu de
patience pour se consacrer pleinement à
sa nouvelle vie d'écrivaine Alizée
cornet est en aparté
[Musique]
laisser pousser oui Alizée il faut
pousser bienvenue
[Musique]
bonsoir Alizée cornets bonsoir
accueillez avec du Mozart et oui vous
avez reconnu et bien entendu oui c'est
pas si fréquent c'est même très
singulier qu'on accueille un invité en
musique et du surcroît avec de la
musique classique vous avez reconnu
d'emblée parce que parce que vous savez
presque aussi bien manier le piano que
la raquette
non non le piano j'ai arrêté il y a
quand même un petit moment mais en fait
on m'a dit que je serai ici chez moi et
je suis en train de me dire j'aimerais
vraiment beaucoup ce que ce soit chez
moi en fait c'est vrai ouais là j'ai un
coup de coeur énorme est-ce que
l'appartement est à vendre
j'ai une petite liste d'attente je vais
pas vous raconter d'histoires
oui on avait envie on avait envie
d'entendre le 21e concerto pour piano de
Mozart parce que vous l'avez joué vous
avez vous avez failli rentrer au
Conservatoire oui alors le Concerto là
je suis pas sûr de l'avoir joué parce
que j'avais quand même j'avais un bon
niveau mais de la jouer ce concerto je
pense pas je joue un peu de bac et de
choses comme ça mais oui effectivement
j'ai failli rentrer au conservatoire et
de faire un choix entre entre le tennis
et le piano en plus je veux aussi au
basket par dessus donc ça faisait un
petit peu beaucoup et j'ai choisi le
tennis évidemment et vous avez choisi
encore le tennis exactement avant tout
et effectivement vous choisissez encore
le tennis et vous avez été bien inspiré
parce que évidemment il y a une carrière
qu'on va raconter 63 tournois du Grand
Chelem quand même consécutif à votre
actif et puis vous vous régalez depuis
des mois ouais ouais je me régale c'est
complètement inattendu en fait c'était
même 107 ma dernière année et je pense
que c'est ça qui m'a fait du bien c'est
juste de lâcher prise un petit peu sur
le résultat et sur ce qui pouvait
m'arriver sur un cours de tennis puisque
c'était censé être la fin de toute façon
ce qui fout c'est à dire que un moment
quand on prend la plume parce que vous
êtes aussi écrivaine on va y venir dans
un instant et donc quand vous concentrez
sur un autre bébé voilà la valse des
jours aux éditions Flammarion vous allez
me raconter la jeunesse dans un petit
instant voilà vous êtes prise dans une
autre activité dans un autre dans un oui
une autre une autre vision et là
sur le terrain vous vous déployez plus
encore
c'est vrai que l'écriture m'a fait
beaucoup de bien dans ma vie de joueuse
ça m'a fait prendre du recul ça m'a fait
me projeter aussi sur la précarière et
sur le fait que une reconversion n'avait
pas forcément être effrayante même si ça
va laisser un grand vide évidemment
quand je vais arrêter le tennis je suis
prête à la petite dépression qui va
suivre et tout ça mais le fait d'avoir
une autre grande passion comme ça à mes
côtés en la personne de l'écriture et de
mon stylo du coup ça me rassure je vais
aller voir le petit oui vous pouvez vous
êtes chez vous effectivement profitez-en
il y a les rituels sur le terrain enfin
rituel ou mantra ou phrase
forte je crois qu'il y a par exemple des
démos que vous dites je sais pas si vous
les dites dans hurlant en criant ou si
c'est plus intérieur mais il y a des
choses que vous prononcez régulièrement
en Espagne
sur le terrain oui plutôt des messages
d'encouragement quand même j'essaye de
ne plus trop m'auto flageller comme je
le faisais à l'époque maintenant c'est
plutôt des messages positifs que je
m'envoie des mots d'encouragement va
chercher ton match j'aime bien
m'encourager en espagnol donc je dis
beaucoup peut-être pour m'identifier à
Rafael Nadal je sais pas qui est pour
moi le plus grand guerrier sur cette
planète qui est devenue hashtag
d'ailleurs votre vamos à vous oui le
fameux que certaines joueuses n'en ont
pas l'air d'apprécier mais mais moi ça
me fait du bien et voilà maintenant
j'essaie vraiment de de garder un
discours positif même si parfois j'ai
envie de râler j'ai envie de d'exprimer
mon mécontentement mais je garde un
petit peu plus pour moi et voilà j'ai
beaucoup progressé de ce côté là dans
mon attitude donc j'en suis très fière
parce que c'était un énorme chantier et
oui il y a la méditation qui rentrait
dans votre vie je crois il y a 4 ans à
peu près ça vous a aidé vous avez le
sentiment que ça vous a permis de oui et
de vous apaiser oui d'ailleurs je viens
de voir le livre de Jonathan même dans
la bibliothèque donc ça me fait super
plaisir parce que c'est grâce à lui que
j'ai commencé la méditation et je le
remercierai jamais assez parce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui a changé ma
vie
et du coup cette pratique régulière de
la méditation ça a permis vraiment de
m'apaiser de d'être plus plus recentrer
dans le moment présent et j'en avais
vraiment besoin sur le cours et en
dehors vous allez quand même faillir
arrêter plusieurs fois ou pas j'ai
failli arrêter
beaucoup de fois oui oui beaucoup
beaucoup de fois j'ai failli arrêter
quand j'avais 19 20 ans j'ai failli
arrêter à 26 ans j'ai failli arrêter
encore en début d'année dernière
mais au final l'amour du jeu il a
toujours été plus fort que tout vous
êtes pas loin du comptoir alors je vous
invite un peu plus près encore de Nice
vous pouvez vous installer il y a
tellement de choses que j'ai envie de
regarder là je sais plus donner de la
tête c'est il y a du chocolat et tout
c'est le rêve ça part tout est à
disposition regardez la chaise de haute
si vous voulez vous asseoir derrière
vous au niveau du comptoir avec cette
vue magnifique promenade des Anglais
bien sûr votre ville de coeur vous y
avez grandi vous y avez appris le tennis
elle sent très bon d'ailleurs vous
pourrez goûter évidemment quand vous en
aurez envie
vous avez expliqué avoir vécu cette
année une rupture amoureuse douloureuse
Alizée vous l'avez dit sans fausse
pudeur très sincèrement très humblement
ça aussi ça permet de lâcher prise en
quelque sorte il y a des douleurs en
fait il y a une sorte de hiérarchie de
douleur mais c'est exactement ça
j'aurais pas pu mieux le dire en fait
c'était non mais vraiment en fait c'est
le concept de défaite de victoire et de
défaite en fait à sembler complètement
dérisoire j'ai envie de dire à côté de
cette rupture amoureuse qui m'a pris
toute mon énergie qui m'a pris tout mon
chagrin finalement et qui m'a fait
vachement relativiser les défaites avant
je perdais un match j'étais pas bien
pendant 24 48 heures je ressassais j'ai
pensé c'était des moments vraiment très
douloureux et là après avoir vécu ça
après avoir
une douleur
là du coup la défaite ça me paraissait
vraiment rien du tout j'ai évacué en une
heure et en fait le fait de ne plus
avoir peur de perdre un match ça m'a
fait beaucoup mieux jouer parce que au
final j'y pensais sur le cours c'est ce
qui me faisait parfois jouer petit bras
c'était cette peur de la défaite cette
peur de cette émotion négative qui
pouvait parfois rester avec moi pendant
24-48 heures et là en fait comme je m'en
étais débarrassé puisque la seule
douleur qui restait c'était ma rupture
et ben j'ai joué beaucoup plus libérer
et aussi il y avait autre chose qui qui
du coup m'a aidé entre guillemets même
si c'est difficile de parler comme ça
mais c'était que le cours était devenu
un exutoire en fait j'étais tellement
mal en dehors j'ai tellement pleuré j'ai
tellement fait d'insomnies que qu'au
final quand j'étais sur le terrain et
que je ne pensais qu'à taper dans la
balle c'était devenu mon ma bulle et mon
exutoire où je me sentais le mieux et
donc le tennis m'a sauvé en quelque
sorte un petit peu
comment va votre cœur alors aujourd'hui
Alizée un peu mieux c'est bon je
t'avance avance doucement il faut du
temps moi qui suis pas très patiente
c'est un peu un concept difficile mais
mais là ça va mieux j'ai j'ai réussi à
me retourner un peu sur toute cette
saison qui est quand même été
complètement folle qui a été
au-delà de mes attentes du côté
tennysique et puis mon cœur c'est un
petit peu apaisé c'est un peu soigné
voilà et puis là je suis prête à avancer
peut-être sur un nouveau chapitre on
verra ça fait trop la célibataire qui
qui envoie des messages ça veut dire que
ça veut dire que vous pensez aussi
j'imagine que vous êtes une jeune femme
vous pensez aussi à la transmission à la
notion de famille alors pour l'instant
c'est difficile pour moi pendant que je
suis en carrière parce que j'ai un peu
de mal à me projeter dans une dans ma
vie après le tennis et dans une vie de
potentiellement de maman ouais ça c'est
quelque chose qui est très bizarre pour
moi à imaginer en plus j'ai une vie
tellement à 1000 à l'heure où je suis
très indépendante et c'est vrai que j'ai
une liberté incroyable à part le tennis
qui me met un petit peu les menottes
mais sinon je suis quand même très libre
et voilà je suis un électron libre donc
c'est difficile pour moi de m'imaginer
maman
elle avait un enfant que je vais mettre
au dessus de tout au dessus de mes
propres besoins
je suis pas contre l'expérience mais il
faut quand même que j'y réfléchisse
parce que pour moi la maternité c'est
pas quelque chose d'obligatoire donc
j'ai vraiment envie de le faire parce
que je l'ai décidé et pas parce que la
société me l'a dictée et je pense que on
est beaucoup de femmes en ce moment à se
révéler sur ce sujet là qui est très
très important alors la famille je ne
pouvais pas ne pas faire le lien bien
sûr parce que c'est l'objet aussi de
votre livre la valse des jours je vous
en prie ce premier roman il est il est
important pour vous parce que il parle
aussi des souvenirs de votre maman
qu'elle vous a raconté Patricia elle
vous a poussé même à envoyer vos textes
des éditeurs votre manuscrit cette
histoire de trois femmes à Nice dans les
années 60-70 une mère et ses deux filles
qui je cherche leur place en quelque
sorte face à une vie compliquée avec des
accros notamment l'alcoolisme la
violence de votre grand-père une
histoire personnelle car c'est
l'histoire de votre maman sa soeur donc
votre tente et votre grand-mère
évidemment on se dit une histoire vraie
quand on est une personne connue il y a
des choses qu'on modifie qu'on module
pour pour préserver ses proches c'est
inspirer de leur vie mais c'est pas
complètement fidèle non plus je voulais
vraiment pas heurter la pudeur de ma
maman qui est quelqu'un de très pudique
donc je pense qu'elle aurait pas aimé
même si à la base c'était un cadeau que
pour elle elle aurait pas aimé
finalement lire la biographie de sa vie
et ça je le savais donc j'ai vraiment
pris mes libertés j'ai vraiment laissé
parler mon imagination ma créativité et
voilà j'ai pris mes zestes en ce moment
où j'ai vraiment suivi une trame qui est
réelle avec effectivement l'alcool dans
dans le ménage dans le dans la dans la
famille dans la personne de mon
grand-père les violences domestiques euh
le fait que ma grand-mère ma tante et ma
mère ont essayé de se de s'émanciper
finalement de cette violence là le
parcours un peu de ma grand-mère qui est
quand même assez fidèle mais après tout
le reste voilà il y a plein de
personnages que j'ai que j'ai inventé
plein de situations où je me suis juste
laissé aller et c'était un exercice très
agréable et en plus j'avais vraiment
l'impression de leur rendre hommage à
toutes les deux à toutes les trois mais
surtout à ma grand-mère en fait qui est
décédée en 2014 et j'avais l'impression
de les retrouver en fait toutes les
trois à travers ce livre et
j'ai pris énormément de plaisir même si
l'histoire est pas toujours joyeuse
c'est la morale de ce livre de ce roman
d'ailleurs je l'ai mis en citation au
début mais c'est comment rebondir en
fait
après des difficultés comment rebondir
après des coupures et moi c'est aussi
c'est marrant parce que c'est la valeur
que je que je défends alors sur on va
dire
un stade un petit peu moins important
parce que ça reste du sport mais c'est
quand même une valeur que je défends moi
le fait de rebondir après après un coup
dur et dans le sport c'est super
important de se remettre en scène le
plus rapidement possible elle elles
l'ont fait dans la vie elle elles ont
fait preuve d'un courage et d'une
résilience hors du commun et je suis
très fière que ces femmes-là fassent
partie de ma famille et qu'elle met
transmise finalement c'est ses valeurs
là vos héroïnes évidemment je vous
invite au fauteuil celui qui est très
douillet vous voyez il est gris il est
tout près de la mer il est trop peu la
Méditerranée je prends mon bout de
chocolat là
la télécommande avec un bouton central
le bouton central on fait on fait un peu
machine arrière allez
et toi
est-ce qu'elle aurait un violon dingue
Manon Paulin oui mais
[Musique]
je crois que c'est le roller oui c'est
ça
pas une distraction c'est un sport un
sport c'est pas une distraction
s alors aujourd'hui on va prendre à se
connaître d'accord
le roller
c'est ça vous êtes super mignonne il y
aurait pu y avoir aussi ça comme
reconversion après tout toujours est-il
que là on est en 2001 il y a une
vingtaine d'années premier apparition à
la télé dans l'instit avec Gérard Klein
ou jouer une jeune prodige du tennis
poussé par un père tortionnaire qui
avait d'en faire une championne il y a
eu des exemples comme ça ça existait
véritable français ça existe voilà là
vous on n'est pas du tout dans ce format
de famine n'est-ce pas un Toulon posé en
fait c'était pour moi c'était un vrai
rôle à jouer puisque mes parents m'ont
jamais poussé à quoi que ce soit c'est
plutôt moi qui les ai poussés à me
suivre sur ce chemin de vie incroyable
et ce qui est ce qui est fort c'est
qu'ils ont être toujours été à l'écoute
ils ont toujours été partants ils ont
cru en moi et finalement je les ai
embarqués comme ça dans ma passion dans
dans cet avisité que j'avais quand
j'étais plus jeune de jouer jouer tout
le temps de gagner si possible mais
c'est vrai que là pour moi c'était de la
science-fiction le fait qu'un parent
pousse son enfant comme ça jusqu'à
l'extrême à un champion c'était pas du
tout mon histoire mais encore une fois
malheureusement dans le sport et surtout
dans le tennis où il y a beaucoup
d'argent c'est quelque chose qui est
très courant et c'est un fléau que qu'on
sait pas vraiment endigué en fait est-ce
que vous sentez rapidement l'intérêt
qu'on vous porte parce que votre papa
Francis c'est ça technique au commercial
maman patricia est agent immobilier elle
travaille ensuite dans une école
maternelle vous allez au club pour
accompagner votre frère il a 12 ans de
plus que vous et vous avez à peine 4 ans
en fait quand vous commencez à jouer
vous vous sentez effectivement qu'il y a
une curiosité à votre égard vous êtes
vachement bien renseigné quand même
c'est quoi c'est ce ce métier de
détective là que vous avez
je sais que ce concept de l'émission du
coup c'était quoi la question je me
demandais si vous sentez assez
rapidement qui a une intérêt pour vous
pour
oui parce que je me démarre quand même
assez rapidement lors de mes premiers
tournois quand j'avais 8 ans je commence
à battre les meilleurs de ligue d'un an
de plus et là je j'assiste à mes
premières rassemblements de ligue de la
Ligue Côte d'Azur ma ligue de coeur
pardon micro
et du coup là j'ai commencé à sentir
qu'il y avait ouais un petit intérêt
pour ce que je faisais même si j'avais
une technique très approximative et tout
ça j'avais des qualités physiques et en
fait et une sorte de grinta une sorte de
volonté je pense qu'il se démarquait du
lot et puis après j'ai continué
finalement à faire mes preuves à bien
jouer à 11 ans je gagnais les
championnats de France 12 ans je gagnais
des championnats des compétitions
internationales et puis ça s'est
enchaîné très très vite à 15 ans j'étais
à Roland-Garros donc en fait ça a été
exponentiellement ça va très vite et
regardez si vous voulez bien en appuyant
sur le bouton
regardez
[Applaudissements]
mon bac français cette année-là
te remercie de cette belle prestation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
2005 vous avez juste 15 ans vous êtes un
bébé en fait 645e chose mondiale vous
venez de passer le premier tour et la
France vous découvre face à celle qui
est un peu votre idole mais il
m'auraitmo 3e joueuse mondiale
bon le score bah il est ce qu'il est
mais c'est pas grave vous vous en sortez
vous faites remarquer et puis vous aviez
votre son poster dans votre chambre
qu'est-ce que ça fait ce jour-là d'en
être là quelle saveur ça a de jouer face
à son idole quelle expérience
fantastique et là quand je quand je
regarde ces images avec un peu de recul
je me dis que j'avais 15 ans ça veut
dire que j'étais à peine plus âgée que
ma nièce qui a 14 ans et demi et je me
dis j'étais sur le Suzanne la Glenn de
Roland-Garros a joué contre la troisième
chose mondiale mais en fait à cette
époque là je réalisais pas ça je
réalisais pas cette précocité moi je
suis rentrée sur le court contre Amélie
alors oui j'étais impressionnée
j'admirais énormément Amélie c'est
toujours le cas d'ailleurs mais j'avais
envie de la battre j'avais envie de la
battre j'étais pas là pour faire de la
figuration et c'est là où je me disais
quand même bizarrement foutu dans la
tête parce que j'avais aucun doute que
j'avais mes chances donc c'était cette
insouciance cette fraîcheur qui m'a
apporté très très loin effectivement là
la revue quand même les pendules à
l'heure et j'ai vu le chemin qui me
restait à faire mais ça
m'a pas du tout découragé au contraire
ça m'a motivé alors c'est marrant ça
chez vous Alizée parce que le mental à
15 ans effectivement vous l'avez vous
entrez sur le terrain vous sentez que
vous pouvez et vous vous dites même que
vous pouvez la battre et puis après on a
l'impression que ce mental là il a
quelques failles parfois je pense que la
réalité m'a un peu rattrapé j'ai quand
je suis arrivée à 11e mondial à même pas
19 ans enfin j'avais tout juste 19 ans
en 2009 j'ai été peut-être un peu
rattrapé par par plein de choses en fait
par cette ascension vertigineuse le fait
que mentalement j'étais peut-être pas
complètement prête à se succéder là
aussitôt
et puis après il y a eu quelques
blessures et d'un coup j'ai tout un peu
remis en question et j'ai commencé à
énormément sur ce que j'avais envie de
faire sur mon rapport à la défaite aussi
j'en parlais tout à l'heure mais ça a
été quelque chose vraiment de limite
traumatisant pour moi dans ma vie je ne
supportais pas perdre en fait c'était
pour moi c'était un drame à chaque fois
et en fait on ne peut pas bien jouer au
tennis si on a cette peur
viscérale de la défaite et voilà c'est
un peu c'est un peu le la contrebalance
de finalement d'être très très forte
très jeune c'est qu'on on prend pas
l'habitude de perdre suffisamment et
puis après quand ça arrive on se dit
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe en fait
comment je gère ça et ça je l'ai très
mal géré et après c'est vrai que j'ai
commencé à revoir un peu à la baisse mes
attentes mes ambitions mais toujours en
détestant la défaite donc du coup ça
fonctionnait pas du tout mais
heureusement je me suis quand même bien
reprise en main vers 22 ans je suis
monté m'entraîner à Paris j'ai retrouvé
une structure correcte et finalement je
à 24 ans je suis remontée dans les vins
donc ça a été une belle revanche vous
voulez bien appuyer sur le bouton bien
sûr
[Applaudissements]
c'est des émotions fortes ça oui
effectivement c'est ce que j'allais dire
c'est on a aussi nous les frissons qui
vont bien on est en 2014 votre victoire
au troisième tour de Wimbledon face à la
numéro 1 mondiale Serena Williams bon
bah battre Serena Williams chez elle
est-ce que s'il y avait un seul moment à
retenir de ces 10 dernières années ce
serait celui-là
ouais surtout que je l'avais déjà battu
à Dubaï la même année donc déjà j'avais
débloqué le compteur je m'étais dit mais
je peux faire des grandes choses dans le
tennis et mais là le fait que ça se
passe voilà cette histoire est très
spéciale le fait que ça se passe ah oui
me donne sur le central pour me
qualifier pour mon premier huitième et
là pour le coup ma grand-mère était
décédée seulement quelques jours avant
le match et je l'avais on l'avait
enterré la veille donc j'avais fait
l'aller-retour à Nice entre mon entre
mon deuxième et mon troisième tour donc
en fait la veille de ce match j'ai passé
mon temps dans l'avion et au cimetière
pour pouvoir enterrer ma grand-mère donc
j'étais pas du tout prête à jouer ce
match là mais quand on parle de lâcher
prise finalement et on parle de
hiérarchie de chagrin mais c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé c'est que
là la douleur de perdre ma grand-mère
était tellement forte que le fait d'être
sur le terrain c'était que du bonus et
ça m'a fait faire ça alors il se passe
des choses aussi un petit peu plus tard
si vous voulez bien appuyer
réjouissances
c'est assez récent ça et oui c'est 2019
désolé les filles et oui c'est Caroline
Garcia c'est Christina ladenovic c'est
Pauline Parmentier Julien mento la fête
Cup face à l'Australie Julien et
capitaine alors de l'équipe vous dites
que c'est un de vos plus beaux souvenirs
ce collectif dans une discipline quand
même si individuelle qu'elle tennis où
vous êtes toujours aux quatre coins du
monde ça génère quoi de différent
c'était une sacrée année parce qu'on
était pas très bien parti on était parti
sur des mauvaises bases au tout début il
y avait un gros problème de cohésion en
groupe je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails mais ça a été vraiment un combat
pour faire vivre ce groupe toute cette
année-là et en fait on s'est tout tourné
vers le même objectif qui était de
ramener la coupe et le fait d'y arriver
tout ensemble en faisant l'effort en se
soutenant parfois on se détestant mais
Julien qui a été vraiment le lien de
cette équipe et qui a permis qu'on reste
toutes soudée en fait c'était une
sensation incroyable parce que une
victoire elle est jamais aussi belle que
quand on a franchi les obstacles avant
et là il y en avait eu des obstacles et
je me souviendrai toute ma vie de cette
victoire et en plus on a on a très peu
finalement de victoire en équipe nous
dans le tennis c'est des victoires
individuelles qu'on partage avec notre
staff mais mais ce genre de d'émotion
c'est vraiment unique et maintenant on a
qu'une envie c'est de c'est de recréer
l'exploit alors Alizée on va vous
inviter en attendant la fête Cup à vous
déplacer tranquillement vers la
bibliothèque mais oui et nous aussi on
était très bien vous écoutez très
agréable
on avait envie de vous interroger sur
deux petites choses vous allez voir une
très anecdotique dans un petit instant
mais il y a aussi une vraie fierté chez
vous d'avoir modifié fait modifier le
règlement de l'US Open pour que les
joueuses aient le droit de se changer
sur le cours si elle le veulent faut
dire que les garçons eux ils ont le
droit d'être torse nu vous vous avez
pris un avertissement en 2018 pour avoir
remis votre t-shirt à l'endroit ah ouais
ouais tout à fait alors je je enfin
j'étais pas du tout consciente de de
l'effet boule de neige que ça allait
avoir parce que vraiment ça a été un
énorme scandale entre guillemets eux qui
sont très sensibles sur sur le sujet du
sexisme et tout ça et du coup oui je en
fait je me suis même pas changer de
t-shirt j'avais mis mon t-shirt à
l'envers je me suis retournée on peut
voir les images c'est presque c'est
presque risible en fait ce qui se passe
parce que je me retourne vers la bâche
je l'enlève deux secondes pour le
remettre à l'endroit et là je prends un
pas un point de pénalité mais je prends
un avertissement pour conduite
antispensive c'était quand même
incroyable moi il faisait tellement
chaud que à ce moment là je suis pas
très très lucide sur ce qui se passe
mais après le match par contre ça a
vraiment eu un ouais à retentissement
auquel je m'attendais pas accessoirement
contribué à faire changer le règlement
et
j'en suis très fière malgré moi un peu
c'était pas du tout mon objectif à la
base mais il faut enfin que les choses
avancent et qu'on arrête d'être choqué
par le corps des femmes c'est quand même
incroyable d'en arriver là le on est
dans une période MiTo évidemment on
parle énormément de ça justement le
sexisme les internautes parfois les
parieurs etc sur les réseaux les
commentaires reçus parfois ça a été
compliqué pour vous beaucoup beaucoup
d'agressivité de violence ah oui ça a
été compliqué au début surtout à la
période où je me posais beaucoup de
questions sur mon avenir sur ma
légitimité dans le tennis je j'ai eu
beaucoup de problèmes avec avec ma
l'estime de moi je me trouvais pas bonne
dans ce que je faisais j'avais beaucoup
identifié ce que j'étais avec ce que je
faisais donc en fait quand je perdais un
match de tennis ben j'étais nul j'étais
une mauvaise personne et c'est vrai
qu'en plus de ça quand on reçoit des
commentaires haineux contre parfois les
médias sont pas forcément tendres avec
nous même si j'ai une relation assez
apaisée oui complètement assez apaisé
avec les médias et les journalistes en
règle générale parce que je leur ai
toujours parlé à cœur ouvert donc je
pense qu'ils m'ont un peu épargné mais
par contre la haine des réseaux sociaux
c'est dur de passer à travers et
maintenant je suis complètement
au-delà de ça je suis blindée et limite
ces gens là me font un peu de peine
Alizée on a une bibliothèque qui est
bien garnie vous avez sans doute repéré
là j'ai besoin là j'ai besoin je peux
résister pas à la tentation ils sont là
pour vous bien sûr vos disques de
prédilection vos DVD non mais là le
Seigneur des Anneaux vous me fait
tellement plaisir alors le Seigneur des
Anneaux je sais qu'il y a une histoire
avec le Seigneur des Anneaux on va y
venir mais en musique vous avez aussi
des des goûts d'ailleurs c'est assez
éclectique enfin plutôt rock rock
Vianney muse qu'est-ce que vous allez
nous proposer à l'écoute c'est vous qui
êtes aux commandes ah j'hésite alors
installez-vous sur le petit tabouret
vous serez plus confortable et je dois
le mettre dessus mon Dieu je me suis
jamais servi d'un c'est ça ça peut comme
un 33 tours alors oui c'est à 33 tours
une platine j'ai envie de faire oh là là
j'aime tellement Vianney j'ai envie de
lui faire bon alors je suis une archi
fan de Ben Mazué mais vraiment mais
d'ailleurs ça a été mon artiste Spotify
donc voilà mais quand même mon petit
Vianney c'est mon chouchou c'est
tellement une belle personne et
d'ailleurs écoutons Vianney ça fait
toujours plaisir Vianney on aime alors
qu'est-ce que je vais pouvoir vous
mettre de Vianney alors je sais que vous
avez un petit fait pour moi aimer toi
mais peut-être pas seulement en tout cas
vous êtes camarade
oui on joue au tennis ensemble on
s'appelle oui non mais c'est on joue pas
de l'ensemble alors à gauche un petit
bouton sur la platine que vous allez
pousser un peu plus à gauche
[Musique]
je sais pas si c'est bonne pioche mais
tout fonctionne avec vous exactement
non mais j'aime bien c'est des textes
simples
et on m'a dit il est toujours de bonne
humeur il est toujours gentil il a des
super valeur
cette fille j'aime bien
[Musique]
qu'avec le coeur
vous êtes bien parti parce que si vous
vous retournez un demi-tour vers la
gauche
vous arrivez dans l'angle du canapé
alors il y a Vianney et puis encore deux
pas à gauche
et là vous allez trouver un bouquet de
fleurs ainsi qu'un paquet qui vous
estimez
pas loin pas loin pas loin ne croyez pas
si bien dire donc en plus ça en a par
terre on a des cadeaux c'est comme ça
que ça se passe
je suis curieuse très ce don
oh
vous voyez vous parlez d'encyclopédie
je vais me mettre à pleurer
c'est vraiment la Bible c'est le
territoire des Seigneurs des Anneaux
la Terre du Milieu merci beaucoup donc
voilà je le montre quand même donc c'est
ça doit être toutes les anecdotes et
tous les
[Musique]
croquisitions
de tournage les entretiens enfin bref
c'est pour les puristes donc c'est pour
vous non mais il faut quand même que je
vous dise que j'ai vu les trois films
plus de 50 fois chacun ah oui là c'est
plus qu'une puriste je suis une une
possédée du Seigneur des Anneaux quoi là
c'est
on est ravi de vous faire plaisir vous
voulez bien nous faire plaisir aussi
bien sûr alors un appareil photo se
trouve dans la bibliothèque côté gauche
donc pas loin du comptoir
bibliothèque avec au deuxième étage un
appareil photo à côté de la photo avec
Gilles Simon exactement alors petite
pastille orange a même l'appareil est-ce
que vous la voyez
[Musique]
d'abord là-dessus ça déclenche
l'appareil en fait ensuite vous prenez
la petite télécommande mini voilà et
vous retrouver cette même pastille
orange qui voilà va vous permettre de
faire le cliché
j'appuie si j'appuie pas sur le bouton
ça va pas marcher
et bah parfait c'est trop cool
impeccable merci
Alizée n'oubliez pas votre la Terre du
Milieu votre Bible donc les fleurs sont
pour vous elles sont dans le vase vous
pouvez les détacher enfin les prendre en
main sans problème
voilà en plus j'adore les roses mais
vous êtes tellement bien renseigné que
ce ne sont pas des roses ce sont des
œillets je viens de voir des œillets de
Nice évidemment pour la Niçoise merci
beaucoup merci merci Alizée la valse des
jours c'est votre livre aux éditions
Flammarion et ce n'est que le premier
parce que le deuxième est en cours alors
le deuxième est déjà terminé je suis en
train de travailler sur le troisième et
normalement pour une publication début
2024 et bah dites moi vous êtes
prolifique et parfait bah vous
reviendrez donc il y a plus que ça
j'espère merci Alizée c'était un plaisir
en tout cas de vous accueillir à très
bientôt je vous embrasse à bientôt au
revoir Alizée
[Rires]
c'est dingue en plus j'avais tellement
de choses que j'avais envie de voir dans
la bibliothèque vous êtes vous êtes bien
renseigné disons
[Musique]
un éléphant roi se trompe parfois et
danse aussi mal que vous et moi en
éléphant moi je ne me trompe pas quand
je me dis qu'il vous conseille